[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous savaient donc créé
montmagny je suis enseignant sociale et
à l'utc de compiègne et aujourd'hui j'ai
déjà parlé
le numérique acsel vous connaissez le
numérique peut-il sauver la démocratie
concrètement le numérique peut-il à pied
la démocratie c'est à dire transformer
ces règles mettre à profit les nouvelles
formes de communication permet numérique
pour tenter d'améliorer son
fonctionnement
première question pour toi est ce qu'on
souhaiterait améliorer le fonctionnement
de la drassm pourquoi parce que de plus
en plus de nos concitoyens considèrent
que notre démocratie est actuellement en
crise que notre démocratie dysfonctionne
at elle bien fonctionner un jour
les exemples sont nombreux de ces
moments où les citoyens expriment leur
défiance
un des exemples récents que nous avons
eu en france et l'exemple de nuit debout
mouvement où les citoyens se sont
élevées ont pris la parole dans l'espace
public pour exprimer leur mécontentement
sur le fonctionnement de la démocratie
cette crise pour résumer elle est de
deux ordres
une crise de la légitimité on ne fait
plus confiance dans nos représentants
dans leurs tâches pour assumer leur
mission de nous représenter en politique
est une crise de l'efficacité on estime
que nos institutions que la démocratie
fonctionne mal cette démocratie serait
malade et c'est un malade qui a connu
beaucoup de docteurs des universitaires
notamment qui lui prescrive un certain
nombre de remède est un des derniers
remède qu'on lui a prescrit au delà de
toutes les réformes divers et variés
qu'on lui propose c'est celui de la
participation citoyenne
l'idée est simple permettre aux citoyens
d'être associés au fonctionnement de la
démocratie
l'idée finalement c'est de repartager le
pouvoir avec nos représentants de
d'entrer dans une posture de dialogue
entre gouvernants et gouvernés
on voit se multiplier ainsi les
expériences où les citoyens viennent
co-construire la décision avec les
gouvernants afin de répondre à la crise
de légitimité
et viennent apporter leur savoir et leur
expertise pour répondre à la crise
d'efficacité et construire une action
publique qui correspond qui
correspondent mieux aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
l'exemple du budget participatif ou un
pourcentage du budget d'investissement
d'une ville comme paris
on parle en millions d'euros a été mis
en discussion et on propose aux citoyens
de choisir les projets qui vont être
sélectionnées pour dépenser ce budget
l'idée de cette participation citoyenne
est en fait de servir quelque part des
cluses c'est à dire de retenir la colère
de retenir la défiance et permettent
juste de petits débordements
pour que le système continue à tenir on
a eu tendance à idéaliser cette
participation à attendre des bons
citoyens qui lève la main avant de
prendre la parole qui ont forcément des
choses très intelligentes à dire et qui
évidemment prennent tout le souci d'
écouter les autres et sont prêts
évidemment à changer d'opinion à vouloir
accepter qu'un aéroport se construisent
à côté de chez eux ou pas évidemment on
attend beaucoup de choses de ses
citoyens et on attend tellement de
choses de ses citoyens que bien souvent
la démocratie participative c'est plutôt
ça des salles à moitié vide
des chaises libres une population assez
peu représentative de la diversité de la
france qui prend la parole dans des
espaces où on parle facilement de
démocratie bac à sable c'est à dire que
ont fait participer les citoyens d'un
côté et les décisions sont prises de
l'autre du coup la question est est ce
que les citoyens arrête de s'exprimer en
politique est ce que les citoyens
participent et bien le parti pris que je
prendrais aujourd'hui c'est de vous dire
que on n'a jamais autant parlé politique
notamment parce qu'on est dans une
société qui est aujourd'hui extrêmement
connectés je pense que vous avez à peu
près tous à quelques exceptions près
peut-être un smartphone dans la poche
vous avez sûrement à peu près tous à
quelques exceptions près peut-être un
ordinateur portable aujourd'hui
connectés à internet
vous avez donc tous la possibilité de
vous exprimer parce qu'une des
caractéristiques de cette de 7
évolution et de cette multiplication des
technologies notamment numériques
et bien c'est une transformation
radicale de l'espace public les règles
de la publicité de la prise de parole en
public ont changé avant il y avait des
gens mon métier était décidé si votre
parole pouvait être rendu public
on les appelait les gatekeeper en
anglais les gardiens de la porte
ça montre bien cette idée d un petit
côté seigneur des anneaux là on voit
bien l'idée tu passes tu passe pas
l'exemple type des gatekeeper c'est
notamment les journalistes qui avaient
la mission décidée qu'est-ce qu'ils
allaient être rendus publics dans
l'espace public
internet a forcé les portes de l'espace
public maintenant on peut produire du
contenu et le mettre en public ce qui
veut pas dire qu'il sera lu par tout le
monde mais ça veut dire qu'ils aient au
moins consultables la publicité devient
une question de visibilité
désormais et cette transformation celle
ce déplacement du centre de gravité de
la démocratie vers plus d'expression et
de discussion plus de communication ç'a
eu un certain nombre de conséquences
on a maintenant un espace public avec
une très forte liberté d'expression vous
est pris l'exemple de wikileaks qui est
un exemple où un collectif a délivré les
informe des livres des informations pour
et lutte pour la transparence en
dénonçant les états dysfonctionnements
je vous ai également pris l'exemple du
forum for tchane amicalement surnommé la
poubelle du web où tout un chacun peut
exprimer
n'importe quoi s'élève donc la forte
liberté d'expression c'est aussi un
espace où on peut évidemment diffuser
des connaissances
le plus bel exemple est sûrement une des
plus belles réussites de l'internet
c'est wikipédia c'est aussi un espace
qui fait une part belle à la libre
entreprise allait à la création et
l'innovation à l'esprit d'initiative
on l'a vu récemment avec ces nouveaux
acteurs qui s'appuie sur les
technologies numériques pour faire
irruption sur des marchés réglementés et
essayer d'en transformer les règles j'ai
pris l'exemple du beurre vous connaissez
ce qu'on surnomme les gaffes à l'égard
femmes
google amazon facebook microsoft apple
c'est aussi un espace où on peut
critiquer renverser la hiérarchie plus
besoin d'être hautement diplômés d'être
membre d'un parti pour exprimer son
opinion
on a vu des exemples plus ou moins
récents de détournements et de critiques
d'une communication qui aurait été dans
d'autres cadres totalement inaccessible
et quand on voit cette transformation
radicale de l'espace public
eh bien on peut se poser la question
qu'est ce que ça fait à l'expression
politique
cette liberté nouvelle
cette capacité à s'exprimer qu'est ce
que ça fait à l'expression des citoyens
est-ce que ça encourage l'expression des
citoyens en france le premier exemple on
a pu s'apercevoir du potentiel
d'internet dans l'expression des
citoyens
il faut remonter à 2005 au moment du
traité du référendum sur le traité
européen
on a demandé aux français est-ce qu'il
souhaitait trans accepter de nouvelles
règles pour l'union européenne les
médias dits dominant traditionnel
unitaire pour le oui les partis
politiques militait pour le oui or
patatras qu'est-ce qui est sorti le nom
et français ont dit non en 2005
et qu'est ce qu'on s'est aperçu après
coup que sur internet avait émergé la
figure du blogueur et notamment un
développeur les plus connus étienne
choir qu'ils discutaient avec un réseau
de personnes qui discutaient avec lui et
qui limitait fortement pour le no c'est
le premier exemple marquant dans
l'histoire de l'internet française de la
parole politique en ligne et ça s'est
développé
autre exemple avec la campagne en 2012
on a véritablement vu émerger la
blogosphère française ou des communautés
se sont mobilisés pour les différentes
familles politiques qui ont tenté de
convaincre des internautes des citoyens
du bien du bien fondé de la candidature
de leur champion
2017 et choses évoluent encore internet
est littéralement devenu un espace de
communication politique comme les autres
on communique tous les candidats sont
présents sur internet à égalité avec la
télévision ou les médias papier c'est
l'ère des réseaux sociaux est ce qu'on
s'aperçoit c'est que concrètement ça
transforme la capacité d'action ça
favorise les mobilisations auto-organisé
l'exemple type c'est les mobilisations
autour de ce qu'on appelle les hashtag
les mots clés sur twitter je vous ai
pris l'exemple de la mobilisation contre
la loi travail autour du hashtag on vaut
mieux que ça ou des internautes lambda
des français ont pu s'exprimer et
raconter leur quotidien
au delà des sondages au delà des
questionnaires ils ont raconté ce que la
mobilisation leur faisait ressentir et
cette expression sensible basé sur
l'expression d'un ressenti et pas
seulement d'une connaissance
c'est une des marques de cette
expression sur internet on parle sur les
réseaux sociaux
en se basant sur son sur son avis son
ressenti et on le partage et d'autres
font monter la visibilité de ce partage
ce se ressentit est-ce qu'on s'aperçoit
c'est que c'était 7,7 capacité des
contenus à circuler à toucher ce partage
de ressenti bien un impact parfois très
politique
on l'a vu pendant les les les printemps
arabes ou si évidemment là la révolution
ne se fait pas d'un sur internet
elle a permis à de nombreuses personnes
de marquer leur soutien de marquer leur
volonté de s'associer aux manifestants
mais il faut aussi avoir en tête que
internet est aussi un espace de contrôle
notamment par les états qui tente de
reprendre la main sur cette liberté la
liberté d'internet est fragile elle et
tous les jours menacée l'exemple de la
sphère snowdon et des révélations sur
les méthodes de surveillance de la nsa
et services de renseignement américains
doivent nous alerter doivent nous rendre
vigilant sur notre cette liberté si
fragile et sur la fragile
et d'internet qui est un espace
d'expression assez hors norme mais qui
peut du jour au lendemain se refermer et
devenir un espace totalement contrôlé on
voit aussi c'est un espace où
l'information peut facilement être
manipulés on peut faire circuler des
contenus faux fossé on a beaucoup parlé
ces derniers temps notamment autour de
la campagne
donald trump de la montée ce qu'on
appelle des fakes news des fausses
nouvelles d'ailleurs c'est pas la
traduction la plus habile fausses
nouvelles le fake c'est pas faux ces
fossés s'est trompé l'autre celui qui va
lire cette nouvelle et on voit bien
qu'on a une véritable nécessité pour
faire d'internet un outil démocratique
un besoin d'inventer des manières de
contrôler aussi de mieux évaluer la
qualité de l'information qui circule
actuellement sur la toile
donc on voit bien que l'internet est en
train appétit pour la liberté et des
menaces qui sont absolument réels quel
impact pour nos institutions
quel impact ce ces citoyens qui
s'exprime est-ce qu'on peut capter cette
participation cette expression et en
faire quelque chose pour améliorer le
fonctionnement d'une démocratie ce qui
était mon point de départ
rappelez vous bien il ya cette
possibilité que en se transformant en
transformant son organisation autour du
numérique en se réorganisant pour
exploiter ce qu'ils les potentialités du
numérique on à la précitée de faire
émerger de nouveaux schémas de
gouvernance on a notamment une
proposition qui circulent qui est celle
de l'open government
ça vient des états unis ça a été lancée
en 2009 par barack obama
et c'est arrivé en france
progressivement c'est l'idée de miser
sur le numérique pour réorganiser le
fonctionnement de nos institutions notre
gouvernance autour de trois piliers le
premier pilier et la transparence la
transparence de l'information par les
techniques d'open data de libération des
données d'ouverture des données
la participation d
citoyens plus de consultation des
citoyens pour qu'ils soient associés à
l'action publique et la collaboration
c'est à dire plus d'agilité dans
l'administration plus de collaboration
entre services entre privé public aussi
pour améliorer l'efficacité de l'action
publique et du fonctionnement de nos
institutions
ça soulève de nombreux problèmes sur
lesquels je n'aurai pas le temps de
revenir ici mais il ya des propositions
comme celle ci stimulante pour
réorganiser nos institutions autour de
cette puissance communicationnel du
numérique et on voit aussi que ya un
mouvement récent on parle de six vittek
de technologie avisé citoyenne ou des
citoyens utilisent de nombreux outils
numériques pour essayer d'ouvrir de
nouveaux canaux de dialogue et de
relations d'interaction entre
gouvernants et gouvernés
- dans mes recherches je m'intéresse à
ses civic tech et j'ai essayé un peu
mieux comprendre ce qu'il ya derrière
et du coup j'essaie en proposer une
classification aucune cartographie en
organisant ce mouvement en n'en rendant
compte de sa complexité
autour de 2 tension de face à face c'est
le thème du jour d'une part leur volonté
soit d'approfondir c'est-à-dire
d'améliorer le fonctionnement actuel de
la démocratie ou de changer ses règles
et d'autre part à la verticale leur
volonté d'être indépendants ou de
collaborer avec les pouvoirs publics
ça me permet de faire émerger quatre
familles quatre grandes familles de deux
d'initiative citoyenne équipés par le
numérique et qui vise à transformer le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
je vous donnerai quatre exemples la
première famille c'est celle que j'ai
appelé les critiques externe
ceux qui souhaitent être indépendant et
contribuer à améliorer le fonctionnement
de la démocratie
là c'est l'exemple d'une plateforme qui
s'appelle nos députés point fr qui est
porté par une association qui s'appelle
regards citoyens dont l'objet est
d'assurer plus de transparence sur le
fonctionnement de la présentation
concrètement c'est un suivi des données
l'activité de nos parlementaires et si
vous avez l'exemple d'une députée et on
a ces taux de présence et de
participation en hémicycle et le détail
chiffré en données de ses activités
actions sur la transparence
vous avez ce qu'on peut qualifier de
réformateurs externes c'est-à-dire ceux
qui veulent améliorer le fonctionnement
de nos institutions
en collaborant avec les pouvoirs publics
en mettant des outils au service des
élus en faisant quelque part de la
démocratie participative 2.0 c'est le
cas de cap collectif qui propose une
plateforme qui peut être utilisée pour
des budget participatif dont je parlais
tout à l'heure où pour organiser des
débats pour mieux éclairer la décision
les élus
vous avez ce qu'on qualifie de
réformateurs critiquent qui sont plus
souvent issus des communautés du
logiciel libre et qui cherchent à
exploiter la capacité du numérique à
faire nombre pour produire des outils en
biens communs et peser dans les
relations de pouvoir avec l'institution
rester extérieur pour transformer les
règles de la démocratie pour monter un
contre pouvoir citoyen enfin dernière
famille ce que j'ai qualifiée de hackers
embarqué à coeur vrai sens du terme
c'est à dire rentrer dans le système
pour en changer les règles du jeu en
utilisant ses ressources depuis
l'intérieur
c'est ce qu'ils vont s'immiscer dans le
fonctionnement de la démocratie
c'est ce qu'ils vont par exemple
organiser des primaires citoyennes
utiliser des plateformes pour désigner
d'une nouvelle manière des candidats aux
législatives comme le collectif ma voix
c'est ce qu'ils vont comme parlement et
citoyens proposer une plateforme pour
discuter pour rendre possible la
discussion par les citoyens des
amendements sur les projets de lois
législatif bref vous l'avez compris il
ya multiples initiatives
il faut rester modeste pour l'instant
elle touche encore très peu de gens
elles n'ont pas encore les objectifs
clairement définis
mais rendre compte de cette volonté des
citoyens de s'exprimer et pour terminer
je souhaiterais vous rappeler que si
importante soit la réflexion sur la
dimension technologique de l'engagement
citoyen réfléchir sur les outils qu'on
souhaite mobiliser ne peut en aucun cas
à remplacer une réflexion sur la
démocratie que l'on souhaite demain à
vous de jouer
[Applaudissements]